kind of universe and men's club Mark
Zuckerberg from Facebook Larry Page and
Sergey Brin from Google Travis kalanick
from uber it's a Pam type world that
seems to be powered by testosterone when
it comes to selling their ideas these
men hit the stage aggressiveness is
listed global in the new power outfit
jeans and a t-shirt fear of failure none
of them seem to have it but the hard
fact is that 90% of all startups
worldwide will go under women think it
twice before taking the plant but when
they do it they're much more successful
than men admitting one of the few female
founders of a thin tech company in
Germany million-volt fad has made it
[Music]
boastful egocentric is that the receiver
for success when kukuczka
well take Oliver's amber there was a lot
of press about his strategy about
signing business plans in blood it was
said to be the most aggressive man on
the internet I looked at that and
thought I would never want to be like
that with a woman is there for you an
example to follow in their static world
there are none unfortunately not that
I've seen anyway it would be good if
there were some what advice would you
give women then would you need to have
the courage to ask yourself what's the
worst that can happen this doesn't work
what then my answer was not much maybe
I'll have lost a year but I would have
learned a lot in the process and that's
about it we need to get better
expressing what we want and at having a
strong opinion one thing is certain we
don't have to copy meant to be
successful so if you have your own ideas
just believe in yourselves don't fear
failure just go for it and do it
[Music]